envie de nous replonger 20 ans en
arrière l'envi de comprendre le contexte
de l'époque le pourquoi et le comment
d'une nouvelle charte pour la france de
58 alors daniel grandclément à fouiller
dans nos archives
or là où soir même de l'adoption de la
constitution par référendum
donc voilà aussi dans le même cadre d'un
journal télévisé 20 ans en arrière
il n'y avait pas la couleur mais déjà
quelques uns de mes confrères et
consoeurs de jambes
[Applaudissements]
de faire de l'intérieur le dernier carré
des journalistes attend la déclaration
de monsieur pelletier ministre de
l'intérieur bien je vais vous donner
sans autre commentaire
puisqu'il y as il ya d'autres
commentaires ils seront donnés au nom du
gouvernement
les derniers résultats de la
consultation d'hier oui 21 millions 322
1211 proportion de oui 81,7 non 4
millions sept cent soixante sept mille
180 en portions 18,3 pour cent voilà
[Applaudissements]
cette constitution qu'une énorme
majorité de français approuvent et fait
le soir du 28 septembre est la
résultante d'une idée de 26 crise
ministérielle et d'un drame
l'idée est toute simple le pouvoir
exécutif doit être fort et bien séparé
du pouvoir législatif
elle est ancienne ce que lance de gaulle
place de la république quelques jours
avant le référendum il le disait déjà 12
ans parade du parlement ainsi composé de
deux champs il est clair que ne peut pas
et ne doit pas procéder le pouvoir
exécutif sous peine d'aboutir à cette
confusion des pouvoirs qu'il aurait pour
résultat que le gouvernement de la
france ne serait bientôt plus qu'un
assemblage de délégation au chef de
l'état
la fonction de promulguer les lois et de
prendre les décrets parce que ses
vis-à-vis de l'état tout entier que ceux
ci comme cela engage les citoyens
[Applaudissements]
les crises elles sont quasi permanente
et très vite il apparaît que la
constitution de la quatrième république
forte en elle-même les germes de
l'instabilité spectacle offre la france
25 gouvernements sont succédé à
gouvernement en place ne ne doit pouvoir
être renversée que si une autre majorité
s'est mise d'accord sur un autre
programme et sur un autre homme pour en
assurer l'application
m
le drame bien sûr c'est l'algérie depuis
quatre ans il secoue la france si de
gaulle est appelée au pouvoir c'est pour
le résoudre et le général ne veux pas
être l'homme d'une situation
et dès sa première rencontre avec le
président coty il imposera avant toute
chose l'idée d'une refonte des
institutions
l'investiture de l'assemblée est acquise
le 1er juin les pouvoirs constituants le
2 tout de suite
dix huit juristes met au travail autour
de michel debré des ministres dont guy
mollet qui affirme l'un pour le
sentiment d' écrire une constitution
parlementaires dont le président serait
l'arbite d'autres veulent au contraire
que le président soit le guide de la
france
en fin de compte la constitution
consacre le rôle prépondérant du
président droit de dissoudre l'assemblée
de recourir à l'article 16 mai laisse
aux parlementaires la motion de censure
les institutions semblent convenir aux
français mais guide ou arbitres on en
discute encore
[Musique]